[Music]
in my bad news
mother submitted by mr. pooper and
Instagram couple sparked outrage for
using holy water in an unholy way
assault douching Wow I'd be really
really annoying sacrilege try think
about the most unholy way they use a
turkey baster for boot doosh doosh doosh
good if you wanted to buy douche can you
do personal douches we gotta go on a
doctor I don't do I don't think it's a
balance assume you can buy at the store
right yeah summer breeze
don't do it no cuz I had like my best
friend's sister growing up she would she
said that she did it and she would use
you know like the old school like water
packs they yeah yeah yeah yeah she would
use that but I'm like how does it work
maybe that's what a douche bag came from
yeah it just comes out that's maybe
that's where the douche bag came from
yeah yeah yeah there's the nozzle douche
nozzle she'd be there do you know more
about what they're [ __ ] us you sexual
dear do like you know videos bro oh and
I'd you know I took human sexuality in
college that's like women's studies like
try to get [ __ ] in that class ain't you
yeah but I learned what that's great so
didn't get any [ __ ] okay
so but this couple so they are from the
Czech Republic named Sabina and zu den
Nick this is what they look like my
fitness ID influenced their people I
mean that's how they reported that Pizza
ain't baked yes so they have 85,000 skin
is they have 85,000 combined followers
and so they recently sparked al are back
lash because they were in Bali and they
were visiting this temple were they
washing their feet in it that's what I
was thinking no tell you because I know
but I'm not gonna ruin it thank
so this is the video that they posted on
their social media and we didn't know it
so we are so sorry what happened
and enjoys to you yeah because we have
we had no idea that that's something bad
we are so cheerfully WeHo you gonna
forgive us and now we are just finding
what we can do to fix it so hope you
have a good day
and we are truly sorry I love how it
they they have accents the apology video
in accents are just whatever they did
wrong it's okay so because if they have
an accent I'm I don't know it makes
everything nicer in again when the hang
for [ __ ] like that you're in Bali so
they were like the authorities there
we're trying to seek like some sort of
prosecution because obviously like
that's [ __ ] up may you don't [ __ ]
around in Indonesia yeah I heard they
just pushed some gay people out of the
building because they're like gay so
that's how hardcore [ __ ] [ __ ] goes on in
Indonesia yeah so social media users
we're saying that this is disgusting and
that they should be blacklisted from
Bali and so what ended up happening is
they they sent this DM inside maybe like
to read it if you want if you want sure
do it in their direction okay
good morning we didn't know it's Holi
what I can
we are truly sorry and of course we
didn't really wash it I had underwear of
course we deleted the video and very
sorry we really didn't know is it
anything we can do
we will apologize on our social media to
all Balinese people came out an
engagement you know what's funny to me I
did what they did was [ __ ] up right
but the funny part to me is having to
apologize that you washed your ass gene
in holy water and and you try to be
funny at a temple like how embarrassing
is that [ __ ] yeah that's funny yeah oh
damn it's rough man it's rough because
I'm just like they didn't know any
better but then at the same time it's
like [ __ ] like don't do stupid [ __ ]
that's what people were commenting they
said as a tourist you should have
learned about the local culture really
yeah what you can do or what you can't
do before you came to the country that
you want to visit not only that but it's
like sometimes it's hard on where you go
like why would you do that peer but like
at least know where you're at like if
you're if you're at a temple and I'm
saying cuz like you didn't just randomly
end up at a temple we don't say anything
like all temples mmm it's like every
every building oh man even respond you
came from a country that doesn't cut
that does it have temples yeah okay well
you still should do your research yeah
yeah absolutely I don't think what they
did was right at all but like just kind
of trying to flip it and see there is a
way to accidentally end up at a temple
records right it's like cuz we [ __ ]
around a lot and let's say we were at a
waterfall in Hawaii or some [ __ ] and
then like I'm like hey guys look at this
and I'm like mooning you guys or
whatever I don't like yo what the [ __ ]
that's our [ __ ] like sacred grounds
man what about a dog [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
like how do you know I [ __ ] up man but
there's a lot of tourists not acting
right right now in Bali I saw this other
[ __ ]
dude he was so drunk right there's
footage of him in the middle of the
street and he clotheslines
a guy riding a
yeah and then the guy falls off the
scooter oh my god yeah and then she runs
up to like a Prius in shape and then he
jumps and in the priest hits him yeah it
looks like the LA crackhead dude just
going [ __ ] nuts on the street man
dude but all he's Australian
well those strike like they're really
strict about drugs and Bali yeah he was
drunk all yeah the one tourists got it
planted on them and they got executed
yeah there was a story about it yeah
Steve Steve forwarded me oh that's a
great way to execute people like let's
say you don't like somebody right you go
to Bali and you go let's party and then
on your way back you call like the TSA
over there be like my friend has drugs
on them and then they get caught and
then they get executed and they're done
isn't that a great idea easy good
actually really is a good idea if you
want you guys want to go to Bali I heard
they got real cool parties yeah wait
you're yeah but what you just telling me
we should go I love who has the highest
life insurance they'll take you to Bali
of zero zero life insurance you all
through yeah you have to be a
beneficiary oh you don't even need to
ask who's got it just put it on them Tim
I'm gonna help you just put it on the
person that you want to assassinate okay
get the real in Bali or Thailand I don't
care if you guys go give you the drugs I
already come off the plane there they're
not gonna be executing people I mean you
might I mean if you're like running
around Thailand acting a mess and it's
cuz you're on [ __ ] whatever yeah you
might get arrested but they're not gonna
like Thailand like hell a
tourist-friendly bail cos dirt that's
one of the biggest industries
yes so as currently I think the number
one tourist country like in the world
yeah that's my mom tells me anyways
she's so proud yeah she really is number
one yeah and but even before that they
love like tourists I mean not only
because they want your money but also
time people Thai people just nice super
friendly culture dude that's not well he
is too though they're super warm like
very very warm people and that all the
hotels are like you can tell they're
like genuinely nice they're not just
like being customer service nice yeah I
felt like they were very welcoming but
yet I just strict on loss so they met up
with the police hmm
like the authorities oh this is they're
still in Bali they should have ran out
[ __ ] idiot mm-hmm so they apologized
and they were forgiven Oh forgave them
who is the official forgiver for the
authorities that's good yeah well
they're saying like that lucky that's
scary I hope they think twice oh that's
nice I got there I was watching a story
about this girl who murdered her mom in
Bali woman she's still alive in the jail
like they kept her alive but they prop
they executed like this old lady that
had drugs on her Oh God whoa
that's how much they hate drugs yeah Wow
damn I feel like if I travel to Bali
they'll execute me just because they
seen a JK uses of me talk about drugs in
the past and [ __ ] hey so like you did
drugs become like you know like a cartel
place or where there's like drug lords
and stuff ah that's crazy yeah how was
it though beautiful it was gorgeous it's
like honestly my favorite place on earth
I heard there's a lot of monkeys that
steal stuff from there yeah you can't be
bringing your [ __ ] there like people
don't do enough research the monkeys
will steal [ __ ] they're really smart -
they're like the pig unzip your stuff
yeah monkey try to steal my water bottle
I was just like oh just a freakin water
well I feel someone's water bottle and
he's like a little monkey he stole it
and then this big monkey came up kind of
snapped him took the water bottle and
dumped it out monkey
funny that is a bully monkey isn't gonna
shoot a water bottle [ __ ] down
something worthwhile steal your phone
they'll steal your glasses they'll steal
anything that's shiny so what he's
supposed to just keep everything on Eli
home yeah yeah put it in like something
locked in your pocket or whatever or
just don't bring it are they sacred
because what if I punch a monkey yes
security guards that have sticks and
stuff so if like something happens like
yeah do you know how a big monkey comes
these your punch punch there might be a
video of a boxing match with a [ __ ]
monkey you went on like a honeymoon yeah
two weeks honeymoon so we went to like
all different parts of Bali because
there's there's like the monkey part
like the ubud it has like mm-hmm
and then there's all like the beaches
and there's different types of beaches
there's like surfing beaches and then
there's like the lagoon like still like
turquoise water would you go with Steve
and then Jess and Joe it was like a joy
honeymoon because they just Lezama and
Joe nation too many dozen Joe's anyway
so these guys here they're also they
also had to do a voluntary contribution
to the local village last time that's
good so they so they paid money yeah
sorry
and like yeah good but people need to
stop traveling and acting like fools a
little bit but just enough to where
you're not [ __ ] it all up yeah for
something like always like really secret
like it's like a very whole place yeah
they got body goes
[Music]